for the brothers and sisters who
keep the quran and maintained it those
are hafiz
i am a brother who did memorize the
quran but i fell off and as we move it's
it's a it's a different dynamic it's
it's completely different it's just love
alhamdulillah
[Music]
[Music]
my next guest went from memorizing the
quran
this is a living miracle for anyone who
takes a look
it is a living miracle and he was the
one carrying it and then he drifted off
ended up in the clubs in the nightclubs
dunya took over now he's on the dean's
show we want to hear his story when we
come back don't go anywhere
how are you doing my brother i'm
fantastic so you were just reciting for
the
muslims out there who are tuning in for
the first time
uh and they're hearing you reciting
something so beautiful middle odious
what will you tell us what were you
reciting alhamdulillah um the story that
i was reciting was the last page of
al-baqarah the last two eighths of
albakura um
i just love that sora my father used to
recite it all time as a kid when i was a
kid so
now your father he was so passionate
about it's not so your father actually
started off
i was going to ask you um
were you a christian before a buddhist
uh hindu and you were like no no i was
muslim born and raised muslim born and
raised muslim born
but then your father was a christian
right my father was a christian um
my grandmother my father and my
grandfather they were in the churches
and my father was
in the church as well
i believe he didn't start
um
started back in the nation
that's where i guess you know for
african-american muslims
we didn't have a lot especially coming
from slavery
so
in order to
change ourselves this the nation of
islam was a beautiful thing for a lot of
black muslims but as my father learned
about learn more about islam and learn
more about
what islam was
he became sunni muslim and
when i was born he was
fully
transitioned into
full sunni muslim
now he had such a passion and love for
the deen for this way of life that he
wanted you to memorize
the quran
so tell us a little about that what age
did you start memorizing the quran
so
i don't remember
actually learning how to read quran or
read arabic i just knew how to read it
when i was when i was younger
my father that's the only thing he did
he just he always recited he always
wanted me to recite he always recited in
front of us and um
he learned that i had a good memory when
i was younger so um when i turned 12
i started memorize the quran and three
and a half years later i was 15 and a
half i'm i finished the quran al
hamdulillah now when i when i opened up
the program i was like okay
you know people can't imagine a lot of
times okay this is a young boy memorize
the quran but then his life
took a different turn
ended up in the nightclubs dunya took
over completely different so it went
from from
uh from the dean to the dunya
what happened
um
and i'm sure this is this is we see this
happening a lot now a lot and this
happens to uh especially um children's
children who grew up in islam
i think as
we grew up in islam um we don't
appreciate because i can't blame it on
my parents because my parents did the
best they can
and
um as muslims we don't really as kids we
don't appreciate what we actually have
and also with parents they'll have um
i believe that sometimes we are too hard
on our children and we don't let our
children really understand and love
islam like we're supposed to
so as we get older we kind of drift away
because it's kind of too harsh or it's
um
like too strict and as we get out into
the world especially in adonia the dunya
got a lot of sparkly things and when you
get into the dunya and you see those
sparkly things sometimes you want to
touch them sometimes you want to do
whatever so
that's unfortunately but i won't say
unfortunately fortunately that's what
happened to me beca and i say
fortunately because um now that i have a
daughter and now that i'm a husband i
really appreciate islam
like truly i truly appreciate islam and
what it has done for me
all right so without going into any
details
of your past
just for the sake of others who are out
there the mediums the aishas the
suleimans the hamzas the esa's you know
so they don't have to go ahead and take
that turn and experiment because some
people they
might end up never coming back you were
blessed that you ended up coming back to
the dean some people get lost drug
addiction
suicide have you known your friends who
had that happen too so
what advice or give us a glimpse okay
because in the beginning you get in and
it's very tantalized you get in and you
should like a kid in a candy store you
know what i mean so what were some of
the things that you were doing some of
the things that you were involved in and
then now comparing it to where you are
now the exp the feeling that you have
now
and the feeling that you had at that
time obviously it kept you going but
then that faded right so let's contrast
both well the same thing like you said
at a candy store when you go into a
candy store everything looks all good
but when you start eating too much candy
you start to get tired of candy you
start to be like all right
this is enough and you start to feel
like crap
and that's how i felt i felt worthless i
felt like dead inside i felt like you
know everything was fun
but
as i got older it was no purpose it was
like what am i doing and so
you know i'm a bouncer i'm a i'm a
security guard i'm i'm seeing all this
night life and things like that but so
you actually started working in the club
also i was working in the clubs i was
then partying in the clubs i was uh
so
literally i was in the clubs every day
and
um it wasn't until
i went to the masjid and and won the
shakes imam 15.
that is a good brother shout out to him
but he met the team asked me to lead the
prayer and i felt bad i was like
leave the prayer i was like nah i can't
i i saw he made me leave the proud but
led to prayer but
um so you didn't totally you were still
connected to the masjid somehow
yeah because people know my father
so
and were you kind of living a double
life here that's exactly what i was
doing yeah so
um
even though i stayed away from the
masjid online i wasn't telling people
what i was doing and i wasn't taking
pictures and a bunch of stuff taking
videos and showing everybody what i was
doing i was doing it and i was just kind
of staying a little quiet about it you
know people who around me knew what i
was doing but
for the most part the
uh you concealed your sins i concealed
myself so that's a good point here that
people if you're gonna end up slipping
up don't go and magnify your sins don't
go tell everybody it's no point what are
you what are you telling everybody so
that means now you have witnesses on the
day of judgment
but um
for the people who are out there man
it's it's uh
the dunya is a
enticing and and it's mesmerizing for
right now but as you get older it just
starts to fade away
and it starts to get dull
and
i i just didn't want to do that anymore
but um as far as the my father everybody
knew who my father was um so
i was watched a lot
and i appreciate that but i was watched
a lot so i made sure i kept
that life away from my father
so alhamdulillah
i was able to
live a little double life and then when
i got back to the
uh oh another story i didn't even tell
you this how about this
i go to a masjid uh one day
and
it was in ramadan
and subhanallah
i went to school in baltimore i see both
of my teachers there both my half of the
teachers there these are the teachers
that taught you the quran yes sheikh
hussein brother muhammad
sheikh hussain walks into me martin did
you did are you are you reviewing
i lied to him yeah yeah i'm reviewing
i'm reviewing lying
my other brother comes to me uh
bruh martin how's your quarter anne
it's great this great is great
ironically both of them tell me go ahead
and lead
go ahead go ahead and leave the prayer
and subhanallah
the same ayah that i recited just now is
the same
i recite it then and i messed up
and that's when they said brother you
got it you got to stay on it so you had
totally gone away from even reciting the
crime i
prayer you weren't praying you were no
prayer no quran no nothing it was crazy
so how did you feel i mean now obviously
you've established you know the daily
five daily prayers
you know the five pillars
that feeling that you get now you know
the contentment the peace you know
living your purpose as opposed to
totally abandoning it
so that so again so aisha hamza suleiman
all the other issa all the other muslim
kids are out there or becoming adults
they don't have to go down that route
now
experimenting so what was the experiment
what was the feeling
at that time
and now shoot the feeling then
was
no purpose empty emptiness literally
emptiness no purpose uh anytime you saw
a muslim you felt bad and any time you
kind of like hit your islam
and
now
i'm unapologetically muslim i see that
yeah i just
listen i'm wearing thobes everywhere i
don't care what's going on i'm reciting
wherever i
if you ask me what it is i'm i'm gonna
tell you exactly what it is i'm not
gonna call nothing
but do you see that because of that
covering up
you know
the the fitra now
you know we have an innate disposition
to worship our creator it's instilled in
us and now you see what you're saying
you're you're living a double life your
conscience is eating away at you we see
a lot of people they end up covering
itself so much and they want to get rid
of the guilt so they they even go to
another extreme and they deny a law they
deny the creator they turn towards
atheism and have you seen that happen i
i see it happen a lot man i got cousins
i got friends i got
you know what it is
allah gives you you know truly when you
really feel bad that's a good thing
don't take it as a bad thing it's a
really good thing because that means you
actually feel sorry for what you're
doing you're not just telling people
that you feel sorry and making like
trying to like
put it on this facade you're actually
feeling sorry and that's what allah
wants
he wants forgiveness he wants you to ask
for forgiveness he wants to bring you
back so when it comes to okay i feel bad
yes feel that guilt feel it because
guess what as you get older and things
like that and as you as these situations
happen again oh bro you want to go out
and drink and all that no i'm okay
because you already feeling bad it's
like if you do something wrong in your
house or something like disappoint your
mom or something and you already if you
really feel bad you're not gonna do it
again you're like man that made my mom
feel really bad and the same thing when
it comes to this dunya like you know man
yeah i did all that stuff it's cool but
or it's fun at the time but
you know learning about islam and things
like that it just makes you feel bad
so
um especially for the children out there
for the for the young brothers who are
out there
when it's time your time to come back
that's when allah is going to bring you
back but inshallah always just try your
best to just maybe slow down a little
bit and then gradually just finish with
it
you spent a lot of time in
vegas also
i spent a lot of time in vegas it was
you lived there lost it for six years
and they call that did they call that
sin city sin city it ain't sin city for
no reason yeah sure is it a big muslim
community there
it's a big muslim community but
unfortunately your environment is still
sin city yeah even though you can you
can only stay away but so much because
as you get older you know you you turn
16 what do you want to do you want to go
hang out with your friends where are
your friends going your friends are
going to
to the club your friends are seeing
drinks your friends are seeing partying
every single night it's just not a i
would say
um
you have good muslims there but it's not
a place for muslims
so what helped you now finally come back
what was it living the double life
you know worrying about disappointing
your father
a sign you were given a sign right you
go
how'd you end up at the masjid that day
now with the two actually your two
teachers were at that same masjid how
did you end up at that day this is it's
amazing
shoot i was hungry
i was hungry
i was just hungry i was i was like oh i
didn't feel like cooking dinner that day
and i was like that's ramadan so let me
go to the masjid go act like a muslim
for a little while and go get some food
and look at allah god almighty allah the
creator having mercy on you look at that
the in the surah i always say
you plan allah plans allah truly allah
is the best of planners
my plan was just go get some food and go
somehow my both my teachers are they're
here from baltimore flying in just to
hang out for a little while
you got to really think see allah sends
those signs it's amazing isn't it
allah sent boxing to me for this
so talk to us about that so you ended up
how did you end up coming back so you
have these and i'm sure there's other
other subtle signs you know some some of
them we see some we don't maybe some now
you reflect you're like oh okay because
i i usually compare it to like a person
if you're just you know um speeding down
the highway the signs are all over you
get pulled over and so didn't you see it
now you're going too fast so you didn't
see the signs like you're going through
life too fast we're not paying attention
life moves fast yeah but now
uh were there any other signs and what
else helped you to bring you back that
you're with us here today
good people
allah
put good people in my life kept good
people in my life
and so
i stopped wanting to lie and be a
hypocrite all the time because
you had people who were looking at me
and because they didn't know my double
life they still were looking at muslim
nahopith
and then you had mo
the the the guy who was selling drugs
and the guy who was drinking
so he got literally two different lives
like
it's just not it's not
it's not cohesive for uh for
for you it's about just living that
double life all the time you just feel
like a liar literally every day you just
for you you try to hide everything your
mom calls you you had a party you don't
wanna answer the phone now you gotta
call your mom that could be the time
that your mom is sick she calling you to
tell you that she in the hospital you
put you in a club and you don't want to
disappoint your mom
anything
or how about this you know you if you
really think about it
what if i died in those states
what if you died in the club
man
and i think about it then i think about
it now what if i would have died in that
state
being drunk being high
dancing with a girl doing some whatever
imagine if i would have died the next
day walked out of the club and got shot
or walked out club and got hit by a car
got in a car accident had a heart attack
anything could have happened
and
crazy thing is now like
man
thank a lot that i i i'm able to
he's given me just a little bit of time
to try to repent try to do as much good
as possible to try to get back whatever
stupidity i did when i was younger how
does this message
get
heard when you talked to some
you know you probably met a lot of
heavyweights in life and i'm not talking
about just literally heavyweights heavy
hitters heavy hitters people who uh have
a lot in life you know
a lot of ballers you call them
people who are very influential you
probably met a lot of different people
uh
and have you gotten a chance to share
your story share your message and how
has it been received sometimes sometimes
you're able to share that message and
people will receive it sometimes
the message is not for everybody i will
say the message not for everybody
because allah literally allah surrounds
you with the people that you want to be
surrounded by
and
some people how about this
i wouldn't say the message is not for
everybody i will say that my message the
way i have received it is not for
everybody like when people hear you
saying take beer and they say you say
allahu akbar means
the greatest and the person is just
thinking like what's he saying you know
and then again there's that button
inside of all of us that made this
position and when you start talking
about the creator you know you're
reciting quran you do it a lot right uh
has anybody approached you people
approached me bro what does it mean
i have friends who do that and i just
tell them yo it just means uh i think
allah like oh allah is the greatest and
what i try to do is i try to make it
very vague like god is the greatest yes
because when you say allah they're like
oh it's like a it's like backup and so
um
just like the prophets always tell them
you have to approach situations
with
caution and you have to approach
situations with
empathy
so
the same guy that you can be like yo
allah is god blah blah blah blah
straight up is not the same person for
this you have to say listen um a higher
entity that we believe in is god we
believe in that and we prostrate to him
um
not because we have to but because we
want to
and so it's a difference you everything
everybody's different the sahabas were
different abu bakr was completely
different from oma and they were great
they they are granted jannah but it's
all about the approach so now we now we
have hafiz muslin
who came back to the dean alhamdulillah
yeah on the dean's show
i would have never ever ever in my life
thought that i would be so proud to be
muslim until now
now i i i'm always i'm just happy
because a lot gave me my some time to
accept
um just appreciate everything that i
went through
so as far as like i don't regret
anything i went to i feel bad but i
don't regret it because i don't think i
would be the person that would be
without going through it because for
islam for me it was a culture when i was
younger and now it's a religion for me
now it's this is really important
because you have a lot of muslims also
who are going through islam as a culture
right this group of people have their
religion we have art they have their
culture christmas
uh and then
they have uh the other holidays that
come with their religion oh we're muslim
we kind of go through the motions also
so that's what you were kind of doing
but now it's a way of life exactly and
and we are supposed to be different as
far as being muslim like
you got christians you got jews they
drink they smoke some of them do
whatever and they're not supposed to
and then when it's time for christmas
now they want to go to church they want
to go to the to
the malls they want to go everywhere but
then when you have a slam we saw we're
supposed to be different we can't say we
drink a smoke and everything and then
when it's e time we want to put on a
scarf or put on a a a soap and be like
oh you know oh i'm muslim alhamdulillah
no no no no we should be muslim
everywhere we should be muslim at all
times we should be unapologetically
muslim anywhere we go because you never
know who's looking at you
never knows looking at you you never
know whose life you could change just by
being
genuinely you what do you think when you
when you do when you see professional
athletes and others who've been given
the spotlight but now they might be very
and i see this a lot people who are
representing their sport very well but
now
like you said they're not
unapologetically they're
apologizing for being
a muslim basically they're very scared
of their brand of their image
to connect themselves with islam
what do you think when you see that do
you see that i do see that a lot but
everybody
uh
has a different path
that might not be their path that might
not be their
their their their journey
and some people are just not about their
life so um and but they might do things
that are that are different so
like um
you might not be they might not be
unapologetically muslim on tv but they
might be the best muslim you might see
on in the street they might be the one
who feeds the homeless every day they
might be the person who
gives by somebody something at walmart
every single time they go to walmart or
something like that they might be the
person that gives that was just not on
tv yeah and i'm the luck um
i guess being the the person that i am
i'm kind of bold and i could care less
what everybody thinks so i'm the lad
allah gave me the platform so i i feel
like i need to use my platform for good
i know what it was like to not use my
platform yeah for good so now
i know like i want my daughter to make
sure that if when she sees me she sees
that i was muslim and she said she's
that i was a brave muslim and it was
okay to make mistakes and it was okay to
do whatever you need to do but at the
end of the day i was a muslim and i was
proud to be a muslim
yeah i think this is very important
because in today's day and age with a
lot of the hate that's out there
[Music]
trying to get people really to
because of all the misinformation
and it's kind of had women taking off
their hijab women getting attacked
muslims scared to be muslims because of
all the islamophobia because of all the
hate machine you know it's a business
nowadays people getting rich in the
business of attacking islam so now i
think this is very important that you
know we we don't bend to that and bow to
that right because you should be proud
one who is submitted to the creator not
the creation you're living a morally
upright life you're good to your
neighbor you feed the poor you're trying
to be a good all-around human being
that's nothing to be ashamed of nothing
to be ashamed of and you also gotta
remember man people
when it when it comes to
this
i guess this error of
you know demonizing islam and and just
making sure that you know people
it's been going on for a very long time
somebody's always doing that either
you're black being demonized your arab
being demonized you're muslim being
demonized but as long as you know in in
in hindsight people people see the truth
because as much as you see on tv the
minute you walk outside and you see
something different you like huh you
wake up but if somebody is seeing the
same thing that you see on tv then
that that's on you and that's your test
that's what allah put in front of you
allah might have put that person that
just
sat on tv and watched a black man me as
a black man
do some drugs shoot somebody blah blah
blah and that's the only thing that they
know and then they see another one so
now they see me i'm muslim a black man
they probably oh
let me back up but then they see i'm i'm
nice i'm i'm talking to them i'm being
kind i'm being gentle and i'm
representing islam right
i might have changed that man's life
who knows
hof is
you showing me some good techniques ah
you were showing me some good techniques
i know how to wrestle now i know if i
ever get into a scuffle hopefully i
don't i try my best not to but um if i
get into a scuffle i got you yeah that
was that was uh that was um usually i
like uh you were holding the mitts up
usually people hold them down here oh
yeah
there's a different technique for that
holding the mitts up is because
people don't understand that if you hold
them is down you know that's where
you're going to punch when you hold them
it's up it's like a technique okay i'm
holding myself you might fight taller
people you might fight shorter people
but you'd rather do something big than
do something like this because when you
do fight somebody big you know exactly
what to do and your arms won't get tired
yeah so that's what i learned uh my my
shout out to uh my coach uh rasheem
jefferson he's a a beautiful person in
my life so uh alhamdulillah it's
that's what he's taught me just jab up
making sure that a jab is strong yeah so
and that was nice you picked up pretty
quick the single leg you know the clinch
you know coming in
you're a good teacher and i'm like
that's what it is you're a good teacher
you're a good teacher also right
it glows so i i have trust in you you
got trust in me so as we move it's it's
a it's a different dynamic it's it's
completely different it's just love
and that's the beauty of islam you know
that's you know people meet each other
for the first time they can be from any
other country doesn't matter they don't
even have to speak the same language
they open up with their greeting of
peace peace be with you
and that love is just established yeah
you could be a garbage man i could be
shoveling uh horse manure it does not
matter just the fact that we love allah
and the fact that we love islam and and
just a beautiful it's a beautiful sight
because
that's what connects us it doesn't
matter what color you are it doesn't
matter what's going on it's just
beautiful bismillah
you i want what you i want for you what
did you want from me or you want for me
what i want what you want for your
brother what you want for yourself and
so when it comes to that you just
you're just sharing this like unity it
doesn't matter where you are so it
doesn't matter where i go i always meet
people and there are people who
if i wasn't muslim i would have never
met they are not in my profession they
have nothing to do we don't even like
the same things
but just because we're a muslim man i
love the brother we cool that's my
brother alhamdulillah i love him
nothing to do with each other nothing in
common either i know one brother who's
like an activist
and
uh and kind of stays away from the llama
like i'm i'm a boxer that's what i do
i'm in the limelight i do things like
that we would have never met if it
wasn't for islam
so that's what you got to appreciate you
when you want something allah will give
it to you allah will put you
um
with the right people and i always make
this do i mail oh allah please
keep me away from the bad and make give
like push me towards the good
so when i see good people i don't care
what they do it doesn't matter i don't
care what you are it's a matter it's a
matter of who you are
a few more questions uh tell me how
important is it for
people to
again when i asked you um you can have a
slurpee smoothie i'm sorry you should
make sure there's green in it so
nutrition
uh this is something that i've taken up
you know really watching what i you
being an athlete professional athlete
you know how important is it for people
to get involved in sports and also
nutrition in your life
so
very important we got to stay healthy
just like allah says you're supposed to
take care of your body take care of your
vessel we're not we can't take care of
our vessel eating bad and working out i
mean it's cool to indulge in whatever
you you need to that's halal and things
like that but
you have to have a balance islam is
about balance so as much you eat junk
food you gotta make sure you work that
off you gotta make sure you eat some
health i mean be healthy eat some
healthy things and make sure that your
your health is good because you wanna
make sure you have as much life as allah
allows you to you know for of course we
can't stop uh um unforeseen
circumstances and unforeseen health
issues but if you have the resources and
need or if you have the ability
to stay in shape the prophets allah said
them the
they stayed in shape the prophet didn't
didn't get into islam until he was 40.
these brothers were wrestling they were
they were getting ready for war the
prophet saws had over 60 wars you know
60 battles sorry
like these guys these brothers were in
shape over 40.
so 40 is not a old age it's a young age
and i'm doing that we got to stay in
shape we gotta we got to be
healthy for our children as well because
when our children grow up and our
children want to go outside and play and
things like that we can be like no i'm
tired because
it's my fault no i got to be healthy and
i got to want to play with my children
things like that
yeah this is very very very important
we've got an obese epidemic of people be
skin fat on the couch not moving sit in
a cubicle not involved in any kind of
physical activity get out eating fake
food yeah
and it's crazy because
subhanallah a lot just just puts these
things in your life just to get away
from all of this because when you eat
the biha
you kind of stay away from a lot of this
stuff you you stay away from mcdonald's
you stay away from a lot of these these
fast food places because not the biha
even though i i eat halal i don't eat
just the biha i stay away from that
stuff too but for the brothers and
sisters who can't stay away from when
you go to the bihar and you only do
halal most of the time you're going to
end up eating fish or you're going to
end up eating some
veggie meal or something like that and
you'll be able to
um
um you know kind of eat healthier but
also you know take a walk after federer
you know take a uh the
right after the sunrise right after you
finish um
your your res recitation or your thicker
take a walk when the sunrise is really
nice outside if you're a night out take
a walk after isha take a walk with your
wife take a walk with your father
you know stay healthy stay healthy
because when it's time to stand up for
tahajjud understand it stand up for
turtle ware god be healthy for that can
we sit down you know of course for our
elders and for our people who are
disabled that's that's what allah has
given us allah and may allah bless them
but for the people who are able to be
healthy and for the people who are able
to stand stand so that's why we stay in
shape alhamdulillah so as we close it up
tell us for the people who are tuning in
and they might have drifted off kind of
like you did
and now they're tuning in
what advice would you give them before
they go away even further but you got
their attention they heard you reciting
the book of allah the quran they're
listening to your story how you came
back what advice would you give them
islam is not a race it's a marathon also
islam is not anybody else's uh
your islam is not anybody else's uh
entertainment your relationship with
allah is your relation with allah and so
what the best thing to do is try to
get back
you don't have to go cold turkey because
that's how people lose themselves again
gradually slowly
get back to praying get back to saying
vicar sure if you don't even say salaam
alaikum get back to san salaamu alaikum
without the law you're going to have to
try always try something better so you
might be out trust me i was out there
and
alhamdulillah i was able to come back so
for the brothers who are out there and
sisters who are out there and and just
trying to figure out something start
hanging around people who do this
something different i promise you you
you you'll it'll it'll start changing
because they won't want to do the stuff
that you want to do
you surround yourself
with people who want who love islam you
surround yourself with people who love
to do it for who love the
the
um
just the way uh uh the way to be a
muslim they they love the islam they
love the the the process
hang around those people i promise you
you won't be thinking about doing
anything else get around good
companionship
yes very important you are who your
companions are absolutely or birds of a
feather flower together yes yes however
you want to say it uh-huh
all right half is wilson
cason really nice having you on the show
you don't even have to call me hoffman
man you know what's crazy for the
brothers and sisters who
keep the quran
and maintained it those are hafiz
i am a brother who did memorize the
quran but i fell off and inshallah male
please pray for me that i get all the
quran back i mean inshallah that's when
i i can i can call myself hoffman but i
can't take that title from the people
who have never drifted off and maybe
they forget a little bit but they they
they they hold on to the quran tightly
those are my true hafiz and so for me
i'm a who is quran i'm the allah i have
the quran with me but i'm getting it
back and when i do really get it back
that's when i can be called a half of
the king we started with we started with
the quran we'll end with the opening
chapter of the quran so if you're not
yet muslim out there
go ahead and listen to this with an open
heart and open mind and earnestly within
yourself ask the creator to have his ear
for guidance and listen to this listen
today and you can actually start
reciting it too
let's start with the
people who uh who
only speak english and don't know what
i'm saying i'll do it in english as well
this is the opening chapter of the quran
al-fatiha
bismillah
[Music]
in the name of allah the most gracious
the most merciful
praise be to allah the lord of the world
master of the day of judgment you alone
do we worship and you alone do we ask
for help
show us the straight path the path of
those whom you have worshipped not the
path of those who who have earned your
anger nor of those who have gone astray
and when we say amin at the end it's the
same thing as amen it's the same thing
as a uh basically
amen
um it means think you know
amen is the finishing um may allah
accept or do i make amend god's
acceptance
i mean thank you brother it's a pleasure
having you on the program thank you i
appreciate it god almighty allah
continue to bless you love you
thank you so much